get ready for the greatest honest
trailer competition of all time Michael
Keaton's Batman versus Christopher
Reeves Superman two honest trailers one
epic showdown stay tuned to the end of
the trailer to see how you can determine
the winner now get ready for Superman
the movie
in a world where comic book movies have
become dark and grim returned to the
superhero film full of fun optimism
bright colors and cab maybe a little too
much can bad vibrations okay okay we get
it already
Superman the movie pseudo for the
superhero classic that proved that even
in 1978 Superman still couldn't get top
billing his own movie instead he placed
third banana two stars gene Hackman
who refused to shave his head to play
lex luthor and Marlon Brando who
producers were too scared to tell that
he was mispronouncing Krypton you are
the only survivor the planet Krypton
Hannah planet Krypton - Gupta - yeah I
got it wrong but which you correct the
Godfather Christopher Reeve is pitch
perfect as Superman a flying Jesus
metaphor who is sent to earth and a
Christmas tree ornament I am sending you
my honest he's a buff boy scout here to
fight for truth justice and the American
Way
I'm here to fight for truth and justice
the American Way that's what I said who
is so fun to watch you'll ignore the
fact that he's kind of a dork
hi and a super buzzkill he really
shouldn't smoking on this plane who's so
dumb he gives away his origin and
weaknesses in an interview I sort of
have a problem seems to live he can't
see through bed but who cares because
he'll always be my Superman
okay look up in the sky it's love as
Superman meets his match in Lois Lane a
superstar writer struggling against her
inability to spell Holly T's in
bloodletting how do you spell mask
there's only one p and rapist what kind
of story is she working on it's a sex
it's about violence got the ethnic angle
seriously what the hell is she writing
she's a perfectly sane person with a
perfectly insane rhyming inner monologue
I belong in the sky watch as she tries
to bang the superhot alien by trading
thinly-veiled dirty talk did you have a
girlfriend
if I did miss lane you'd be the first to
know about it I assume then that the
rest of your bodily functions are normal
color underwear am I wearing pink in a
conversation so steamy Superman will
turn back time to save her which he dies
in an earthquake hey Supes I know she
was your girlfriend but a couple more
spins could have undone the entire
earthquake saved a few lives billions of
dollars of property damage but I get it
you're in the pink I like pink very much
Lois strap in as Superman faces off with
his nemesis Lex Luthor a criminal super
genius who dresses like andre 3000 watch
as this infamous super criminal
challenges the Man of Steel with an
overly complicated plot that involves
using missiles and earthquakes to
destroy California so that he can turn a
bunch of desert property purchased into
beachfront real estate hostile dialects
dude if I wanted to see an industrialist
with a bad wig talk about real estate
I'd watch the presidential debates am i
right
zing uh so return to the movie that
pioneered the tropes comic book movies
have been following ever since like
setting up sequels
unnecessary origin stories for popular
characters shoehorning in comic book
lingo is fortress song using time travel
to fix your mistakes
destroying famous landmarks and sky
beings dad are you still talking about
that old Superman movie what are you
doing down here
go bother your mom I think it's so
boring the new Superman has super cool
fight scenes this one has tons of action
too let's see there's oh well what about
come on there you go miss holy crab
there aren't any fights in this whole
movie also it look is done when your
Superman flies new Superman looks
totally awesome when he flies look in
1978 these special effects were awesome
okay and hey at least my Superman didn't
kill anyone actually I really
appreciated Cal's value for life being
something he has to earn by being forced
to take one as a pantheon of American
pop culture Superman should evolved to
reflect society for what it is not what
we wish it was just get the out of
my booth
starring friendly Cavill white rashida
Jones Jesse Eisenberg senior Peter
Parker and the gods father fun man of
steel was it necessary to see baby
Superman's bait and tackle you've seen
Superman defeat Lex Luthor
now click the box above to see Batman
take on the Joker in this epic
competition between two honest trailers
are you team Superman or team Batman
we'll determine a winner based on the
only thing that really matters fuse if
the Caped Crusader gets more views we'll
make an honest trailer for Batman Begins
if the Man of Steel dominates we'll do
one for Superman Returns so click on the
box above to see the honest trailer for
Batman 89
be sure to watch and share because the
fate of Batman and Superman are in your
hands
give me more than one slice of banana
bread or I will lose all control one
batch to batch penny and dime hey
everyone stop the Planet of the Apes I
want to get off fire the manatee cannon
Batman hates Superman because he stole
his guacamole have you ever danced with
a devil in the pale moonlight